أريد تشغيل مقطع الفيديو هذا من
كاميرا الجسم الثالث ومن ثم
يمكننا أنا وأنت مناقشة أنه من المحتمل أن يكون الفيديو
الأكثر صعوبة في مشاهدته
ولكنه يعطينا فكرة عما كان
يحدث هنا، لا بأس،
حسنًا
حسنًا يا رفاق،
أنتم تفعلون الكثير حقًا
الآن يا أخي، استلقِ على الأرض،
أنا لا أفعل ذلك،
يا إلهي،
يمكنك أن ترى هناك في النهاية أنهم
يحاولون تذوقه ولكن هذه هي
المشاجرة الأولية حيث
لا يكونون كذلك، فهو يسألهم ما الأمر  يحدث وهم
لا يشرحون ذلك العدوانية،
نعم، لقد تم تعليم ضباط الشرطة الآن
تخفيف التصعيد، ولا ترى أي
تخفيف للتصعيد ولكن هذا صحيح، وهو تصعيد
كامل لأي سبب ولأي سبب
ويتعارض مع
كل ما تعلموه و  لقد
تدربوا على القيام بذلك وكانوا غاضبين لقد
جاؤوا ساخنًا نعم لقد جاؤوا ساخنًا